if you expected science to give all the  answers to the wonderful questions about  what we are where we're going what the  meaning of the universe is and so on  then I think you could easily become the  solution the way I think of what we're  doing is we're exploring we're trying to  find out as much as we can about the  world  and therefore when we go to investigate  it we shouldn't pre-decide what is this  we're trying to do except to find out  more about it you see one thing is I can  live with doubt and uncertainty and not  knowing I think it's much more  interesting to live not knowing that the  have answers which might be wrong  I don't feel frightened by not knowing  things by being lost in the mysterious  universe but it doesn't fight me my  interest in science is to simply find  out about the world